hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 legends of chess tournament
uh it's a game that a lot of you have
requested but we didn't get time to show
now from the match
boris girlfriend versus rishwanatan
anand and this is the first game of
their match
uh so let's see why so many of you have
requested it
and it is a very nice game uh so without
further ado uh let's check it out and
also
i got a new pc so if uh you know i don't
know if you guys uh
if anything is different do mention in
the comments if everything is okay with
the sound with the audio uh with the
video as
this is the first time i'm recording
with the new setup like everything is
much smoother on my end so
even though if there's no difference for
you i hope you guys are happy for
everything going smooth on my end but
like
i'm i think like there should be you
know some more frames or
you know should be smoother uh but
uh you know uh and also the board should
uh
be much quicker uh but we'll see so uh
without further ado let's check it out
the bodice with the white pieces opens
with uh
d4 now we have knight to f6 by on and c4
e6 and of course we go for the queen's
gambit decline knight f3
that's not a queen's game with a decline
uh whoa sorry about that
uh d5 and we have the queen's gambit
decline we have g3
seems the the the new setup is a bit too
fast
and the bishop to be for with check and
here uh uh anand is uh checking will
what is the block with the knight like
this like this like this with the bishop
or what so bishop to d2 boris offers a
trade
and anand goes back so losing a temple
but boris will also need to
waste the tempo as the bishop is kind of
kind of weird on d2
so bishop to g2 and anand castles we
have queen to c2
and now knight b to d7 so just nicely
continuing development
and the disposition has been reached in
top tier tournaments like
almost 70 times and the go-to move here
is just castles but
boris as he's a great student of the
modern uh opening theory you know
sponsored by neural networks uh goes
h4 and it is a new move in the position
so already as a move eight we have a
completely new game
uh anand continues to uh just uh develop
we have c5 he strikes in the center
as you should it is very principle to do
that especially since uh gervans king is
still in the center of the board
so c captures e captures and now knight
the c3
just continues development the rook to
e8 and now of course boris castles the
safety
uh we have h6 bayonet taking away the g5
square
uh from black's pieces and now bishop to
f4 so this is the moment that we've
mentioned that boris will also need to
waste the move
uh that um well the bishop just
isn't all that impressive on d2 so here
bishop to f4 eyeing that c7 square ideas
like knight b5 to c7 might be a
problem for black in the future so a6
taking away the b5 square from
uh griffin's knight and now rook 8 to d1
continuing development we have c4 by
anand kind of anti-positional
but you know if it works why not here he
abandons the fight for the central d4
square
but he is preparing b5 b4 and so on so
of course
uh boris needs to do something about
that first he goes knight to e5
opens up the diagonal of this light
square bishop and of course his plan is
to play some like b3
capture here captures and e4 and grab
full control of the central squares
so knight to b6 by anand and now b3
of course going for that uh center we
have
bishop to b4 by anand and now captures
on c4 we have captures on c4 and now
that
this bone is no longer fighting for the
e4 square a girlfriend pushes e4 and now
you can see that uh girlfriend controls
a lot of squares here he still has the
bishop pair
so white is definitely a little bit
better here and anand has this
uh well weirdly placed knight on b6 so
we have
a5 and grabbing more space on the queen
side now the bishop is also defended and
knight to b5 he has he allowed it so
boris takes advantage of this b5 square
and now if this knight moves let's say
captures then of course knight to c7
will
will be an idea so knight to h5 anand
wants this bishop to just move away
with bishop to e3 and now bishop to d7
forcing this knight to move back or
offering it to to this knight on e5
and it kind of looks weird just giving
up uh this knight
uh for this bishop on d7 as it seems
like this bishop is
this knight is way stronger than this
bishop but uh much like in the case of
uh
bobby fischer versus tigran petrossian
uh
it's sometimes just better to capture
the inactive piece as it might become
incredibly active so and if you don't
know which game i'm talking about i will
put a link to it in the description
below it's really an awesome game
so knight captures on d7 uh rather than
just retreating with the knight we have
queen captures and now a4 defending this
knight here
we have knight back to f6 by anand
preparing a very nasty trick
uh one that uh well now that now that i
mention it like this it
does remind me of of bobby fischer's
game of the century
so here uh d5 by boris you can see how
much uh squares uh boris controls here
the the bishop is excellent attacking
this knight here the rooks are excellent
uh well not this one but uh once once
it's developed
it will be and of course the the two
central pawns are
very impressive so here anand really
doesn't have
all that much to do and also d6 is just
coming which will be very annoying
so uh anand has one move that really
helps him out in this
in this position so feel free to pause
the video here and try to figure it out
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
figuring out that uh by mentioning a
bobby fischer's game of the century i
was talking about the knight the a4 move
uh and now that you that now that you
see it it kind of does make sense
because even though the material on the
board is equal
anand has three pawns here on the queen
side boris has only one and here anan
just eliminates that one
uh he gives up a piece for it but now uh
he will have three pawns
on connected ones on the queen side so
boris accepts the challenge
uh with queen captures on a4 you could
not accept b's like you could go e5 and
just consider it a trade to make
the game a little bit crazy for example
captures captures
and now the queen guards the knight for
example queen d7
you can even capture here but it's hard
to hard to decide whether this is better
probably is but boris uh boris respects
a good piece so he plays
the queen captures on a4 uh and now
knight captures an e4
uh as now the nothing is uh defending
this pawn anymore we have bishop
captures and the rook captures so uh ana
now
has two points for for the piece knights
the c3 now with a double attack
attacking the rook and also the queen
here so
anand the must trade queens here so
captures captures and now
b5 and all of a sudden anand has three
connected pass pawns on the queen side
and boris is up a full knight
so knight to b6 attacking the rook and
rook to d8
now just hoping to block off the the
pass the d-pawn we have bishop to f4
hoping for d6 now that the bishop and
the rook will be
guarding it d6 d7 is coming so bishop to
d6 anand blocks it and
makes room for his own past pawns to be
pushed forward
so bishop captures we have rook captures
and now knight to c8 going after this
rook rook to d7 and now
d6 boris could also try to repeat with
something like this just uh this and
this but i'm sure boris is uh still
trying to win this as he he is up a
piece and you have to respect a full
piece especially if like
like it's if it's a knight so d6 uh and
now comes c3 now anand starts pushing
his pass pawn we have rook to d5
going after the b5 pawn and b4 and now
we have this very interesting position
where boris has to decide whether to go
for this a5 pawn or not
uh of course it's much of a too big of a
decision to make in a rapid chest when
the time on the clock is ticking but i
will show it as it's incredibly
interesting if
you go for the a5 pawn then c2 is coming
and now you have to
of course see if you if you were able to
stop both of the past pawns so the point
is
97 check king h7 knight f5 you
re-maneuver the knight all the way here
to defend the the pawn like this
uh rook the c4 now preparing to just win
the rook and
now rook to c1 block it now comes b3 and
rook b5 now preparing to win the b3 pawn
and here black will just say okay g6 you
move your knight i'm going to capture
this pawn and i'm still going to have a
very nice position but
this is where white has to accept the
draw with rook captures here and now
after everything gets traded off rook b2
will go after the spawn
captures and now let's say captures
captures and captures and we have this
completely equal end game and now of
course it's a draw
so uh rook captures uh leads to a raw
where boris calculated this and said uh
no i still i'm still up a piece i still
want to win this
or was it maybe too much to calculate
for uh such little time on the clock
uh i guess uh we will not know uh but it
was interesting so here
knight back to b6 by boris we have rook
to d8 and now
d7 now he got his pawn all the way to d7
and now if he can get rook to c5 to c8
uh in there it's just game over as the
knight defends this uh
so that's his plan and you have to be
very careful
uh like if you do something weird that
this is coming so uh we have
rook the e6 now going after the knight
now rook c5 of course rook captures
knight but now comes
knight to a4 and rook to c6 by ana now
preventing this
but uh now uh girlfriend finds a
different strategy knight to c5
again defending this and now he wants to
go in this way
maybe you can even go like this but it
would be dangerous to to get this rook
away from the defense of the
of the queening squares so here we have
rook the c7
you could try even something like rook
captures rook captures and rook captures
here
uh and then try and see whether the
three pass pawns would be
uh sufficient for the extra rook but uh
all in all this is also a draw
uh with for example if rook to a1 going
after the pawn
you're going to go rook d2 take care of
the this square and now
after this pawn is captured you're going
to play b3
and now after this pawn is captured
you're going to play rook to d1 check
king g2 and b2 and now of course the
pawn is queening
white will stop it but at some point you
will have to
give up the rook and now again you will
just stray down into a draw
so it is possible at any point you can
go for this but
rooked back to c7 on and once uh anand
still wants to win here
and this is why this game is so nice uh
at any point anand can go for a draw and
boris can go for a draw but they
both want to win so here rook the e5 now
threatening this if it comes with check
it's game over because you either win
the rook or
rook captures followed by pawn captures
with a promotion
so king h7 and now comes rook to a1
uh if rook to e8 now then you just
capture this pawn and now the rook is
hanging
so here you'd have to trade and now of
course black is completely winning
the three connected pass pawns are much
stronger than a knight
so here rook to a1 now finally boris
goes after the a5 pawn but now
anand finds a4 and a4 is really awesome
because if knight captures then you get
rid of this pawn
and without this spawn white will be in
in very big trouble
uh so here uh girlfriend goes for rook
captures on a4 instead
but now c2 now girlfriend has no rook
defending the c1 square so he has to go
back
if you go knight b3 it's not enough for
example you just capture the pawn and
now after rook captures here
now you find the absolute brilliant rook
the c3
next move you can just capture and
promote to a queen knight c1 doesn't do
anything because rook d1 check picks up
the knight
if rookie one again just rook to d1 and
it's game over
so here of course anand would be
completely winning so
rook back to a1 you you need to keep an
eye on this square and now finally
rook d captures on b7 anand now gives up
the exchange
but basically what he does is uh allow
boris to be up
a full rook so here knight captures rook
captures and we sort of have this uh
young gustafson end game where one
player is up a rook but
the problem is uh it's not that easy to
play with the two rooks because
these two pawns are just incredibly
strong so here
boris plays rook to c5 as you should
always put a rook behind the pass pawn
like unless you shouldn't uh here
it's uh definitely one of those cases uh
the eternal between
rook to e1 or rook to c5 but rook to e1
might be a bit more resilient although
in a rapid game with very little time on
the clock calculating this
is is a nightmare for example rugby for
example if b3 rook
ac1 now of course if this you can
capture so of course black would defend
and
now uh you go king g2 and now finally
after b2 you ignore black and just
continue with king of three
uh because now you say okay i have to
give up the rook so captures uh
with captures and now the the thing is
is this winning or is this a draw
uh it is unless it's some sort of a
famous study it should be
should be should be winning for black
king g6 a king e2 and now king f5
and now the problem is you either allow
the black king to enter your pawns or
you
block him but then comes rook to c3
another problem is if you go here to win
this pawn then just captures captures
you start giving up
pawns on the king's side and if you try
to waste moves let's say king of two
then let's say h5 king e to g5 captures
captures king f2 and now
finally f5 and with f4 you will create a
past
h pawn which will be which will be
winning for example king e2 you repeat
f4 king f2 captures captures h4 check
you're gonna go king f2 or g2 king f4
and now finally after this
h3 and now these two squares are covered
from the white king
and there is nothing more to be done
here king e2 h2 you're gonna go here h1
queen
captures and now finally this uh
uh win wins the game so it is very
interesting
uh but it is very resilient but in the
end it should also be losing for white
so boris instead
went rook to c5 he just put the rook
behind the pass pawn
but this also is insufficient anand
plays b3
now defends his past pawn uh rook to f1
he doesn't want to allow rook to d1
uh to come with check so rook to f1 and
now rook to d1
uh all the same here boris played king
to g2 but now
feel free to pause the video here and
win the win the game for anand in the
fastest way possible
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's rook
captures on f1 and now after king
captures on f1 just b2 and now one of
the two
pawns is queening and white is unable to
do anything about this and it was in
this position on move
45 that boris gale fund resigned the
game uh and
anand was able to win game two as well
game three was a draw so anand
uh won the match against guelph and
without even reaching game four
so here you resign because of course if
captures this comes with check and once
the king moves just
uh capturing it i will mention something
if you enjoy playing bullet uh
you might uh find yourself in a position
like this
and often uh it's uh interesting for
example if this happens and you're in
this position and you're playing white
uh and someone plays something like this
then just play this block it
with uh rook to c1 because your opponent
might pre-move this they probably think
you you will play king here
and then they pre-move this so if you
play rook to c2 they might remove this
and you just win the queen
and you know i i've tried this um like
so many times and
it works like 10 of the times but still
you know try it
if if you're into bullet but yeah after
b2 uh boris
resigned and an excellent victory for
vishwanathan anand that
uh whole line starting with knight
captures on a4 with the night sacrifice
was
incredible so uh once again uh i do hope
you enjoyed it
i would like to thank edward edison
apostles
[Music]
juan vincent alvarez and glenn mangle
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of the chess 24 legends finals checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your friday
and do mention if everything is okay
with the video the audio as this is the
first video i'm recording with the new
setup
uh see you soon